There was a time when our city streets sounded like this.
Today,
they sound like this,
but what will the streets of tomorrow sound like?
Okay.
By 2040 it's predicted that 35% of the world's cars will be electric,
and from there it's only a matter of time before the internal combustion engine
sputters out for good.
How much will that change our world?
Could the electric car save our climate?
Will it improve our health?
What does today's data tell us about tomorrow?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if all cars,
when electric in 2017 carbon dioxide emissions in the United States for the
lowest they've been since 1992 but at 5.1 billion metric tons,
there's plenty of room for improvement.
Fossil fuel cars and trucks accounting for nearly 30% of America's carbon
emissions scientists,
experts in innovators have shown that electric is the way to go.
Electric cars are four times more efficient than gas powered vehicles.
That means that if everyone in the United States made the switch,
the country's carbon dioxide emissions would immediately drop by 8.4%
admittedly,
this wouldn't be an easy transition.
Since today's electric cars are on average,
$20,000 more expensive than most other cars on the lot.
A country full of electric cars would see the demand for electricity jump pipe
are 29%
but with more than half of American electricity being produced by fossil fuels
with the change even be worth it,
it seems like it.
In recent years,
the United States has been turning towards more renewable energy sources to
produce electricity and it looks like electric cars are going to become more
convenient.
Car companies like Chevy,
Nissan,
and Tesla are set to reveal long range electric models for an affordable $30,000
with everyone driving electric greenhouse gases would go down while green energy
and green jobs would go up.
Even today,
solar panel sales are doubling nearly every year.
Not to mention 50,000 Americans die prematurely every year from illnesses caused
by carbon
missions.
Millions of healthcare costs could be saved by the electric car.
But while all of this may sound too good to be true,
this what if might actually be closer to when electric car sales appear to be
growing by 60% every year.
Ford's model t showed a similar growth rate around the time the car over took
the horse.
So buckle up and hold on tight because the future is coming up fast in time.
We'll see what the road of discovery has to offer,
but why wait?
Recharge yourself soon with some more.
What if.